réparé hier après l'incident les
canalisations ont été consolidées ce
matin à l'entrée de la ville
il a fallu découper la partie
défectueuse pour la remplacer par une
nouvelle
la fissure impressionnante s'étalait sur
à m elle a causé une grosse fuite d'eau
en début d'après midi dimanche à une
vitesse de 800 mètres cubes par heure
résultat 80 % des habitants ont été
privés d'eau potable et une vingtaine de
pompiers a été mobilisée pendant
plusieurs heures des travaux rendus
difficiles par la rupture d'une
canalisation de gaz pendant
l'intervention lors de deux des travaux
pour rechercher cette fuite
une pelleteuse de suez a accroché une
ancienne conduite de gaz qui nous a
engendré une complication dans cette
intervention
c'est à dire que nous avons une fuite de
gaz et nous avons donc stopper les
opérations fait un périmètre de sécurité
est donc appelée des moyens
supplémentaires en cas de risque
incendie
pendant plus d'une heure les habitants
ont été confinés chez eux par mesure de
sécurité
tout est rentré dans l'ordre dans la
soirée l'eau est revenu vers 22h30 pour
la mairie des canalisations vétustes
cumulée à une surpression pourrait être
à l'origine de l'incident
c'est vrai qu'on a des canalisations bas
qui parfois sont anciennes donc il ya
des phénomènes d'usure naturel des
réseaux en fonction de la période à
laquelle elles ont été implantées de
l'état des raccordements qui peuvent
exister et puis à des phénomènes aussi
particuliers comme des éléments de
surpression un moment donné on a une
arrivée d'euros plus forte qu'à
l'accoutumée qui peut expliquer que sur
une canalisation en partie fragile on
puisse avoir une rupture comme celle
d'hier assez exceptionnel parce que sur
une fissure d'un mètre c'est quand même
pas courant un état de la situation
générale du réseau devrait être opéré
par la mairie dans les prochains mois
pour éviter d'autres incidents de ce
type